matt moore making his seventh start
he's on one with a 5.40 earned run
average
and lines winning to right field there's
a base hit
leadoff man on for the marlins in the
first against matt moore two balls two
strikes
swing and a miss he threw a change up
and it's the best one so far and what
out here in the first
that's a base hit into center field
and mickey's on his way to third
so the marlins have him on the corners
now
swinging a miss
and the side is retired no runs two hits
and two men left
and for the marlins it's sandy alcantara
this is his 20th start of 2021.
showed you earlier 116 and two-thirds
innings pitched in the first half that's
third best in baseball second in the
national league
holds sharply that's a fair ball going
down the right field line it skips off
the half wall
cooper's trying to get to it harper's
getting the second he's there standing
his 15th double of the year
and ball four reese draws a walk to put
two on for dd gregorius
runners go
and a pitch low ball four and the bases
are loaded for jankowski
broke his background ball it's a fair
ball leaked right down the right field
line one run is in here comes hoskins
teeny's around third he's being waved
home the throw to the plate not in time
it's the slowest faces clearing double
you'll ever see
and the phillies take a three-nothing
lead
1-0 to ronald torres
who shoots one to right-field a line
drive that cooper goes up and gets
two balls and two strikes to jazz here
it comes from moore that one is ripped
fair and this is going to go toward the
corner
it'll be extra basis for jazz chisholm
junior who cruises into second
a lead off double for the marlins one
and two to verdi
and it's in the air right field harper
going back he turns he'll play this one
off the base of the wall
jazz is around third he's coming in to
score no throw and it's the second
double this inning for the marlins as
john bertie makes it a 3-1 game
and miggy into right that will fall fair
birdie's going to come in to score
and rojas is on his way to second with
an rbi double
and the pitch
and a strike three on the outside corner
93.
five strikeouts for matt moore through
two at eights
now good change up from sandy for out
number one
2-2 pitch is swung out and missed that
strike three a fastball away at 98.
and he gets just that strikes out the
side
over the mounds
chisholm oh he should have let rojas
handle it
and the phillies have a two out base
runner who balls two strikes hoskins
goes outside ball four
alfaro is running to third just in case
uh hoskins thought about taking off as
the two runners lead off the pitch
coming in and he lines it to left field
that's a base hit he'll get at least one
they're gonna hold dede the throw to the
plate is a one hopper an rbi signal for
jankowski he's got four stakes today tom
goes from first again puts grounded back
toward the middle into center field a
base hit dede scores after getting the
second on his belly jankowski scrambles
to his feet and gets to third
the phillies get an rbi single by tires
5-2 here in the third
and the
swing
one-two
a miss
he went softer one-two pitch coming down
farrow swag and a miss he got it with a
change-up
the lead hoskins to the bag seven
strikeouts for matt moore and the
one-two pitch
swag and a miss he's got eights
for the first time since 2017
matt moore has struck out at least eight
in a ball game
segura's over two
and he lines one to center field make it
one for three
a one out single
[Applause]
he deals a one-two pitch to williams
that's grounded up the middle miggy will
take it himself
and turn the double
play and a cold strike three nine
strikeouts for matt moore
no one pitch coming to rojas
ground ball past
reese hoskins into right field rojas
takes the turn around first holds up
there that's his third hit of the day
so 79 pitches for matt moore he strikes
out nine but his afternoon is complete
archie bradley will be the new pitcher
for the phil's
over to third diving stop to raise from
his knees there's one and two
oh man what a play all the way around
look at the reaction from matt moore in
the dugout
torrey has started it flipping some
leather and then gene segora throwing
some gas over to first base
it's going to be a tough play toures
charges bare hands throws in time
ronnie
how about the last month of the season
for the reyes and what he has done
offensively and defensively
by
[Applause]
fires and jankowski
aguilar off the bag
no big deal just a three-hit game
looks like pop wanted no part of that
bunk
all four
the touch emphatically walks as a pitch
hitter to put runners on first and
second for segora
and sigour is hit by that pitch
and that'll load the bases up
pop brings it home and a cold strike
three time of the zone
well ranger suarez is getting kind of
popular ben
lefty's set to go in the pitch
and a call strike three 95
i'm not really sure what alfaro was
thinking was gonna come in there
one out here in the seventh
and a calm strike three this time 94.
similar spot to alfaro
and two outs here in the seventh inning
and again we wonder what they're looking
for
they're the o2 pitch
and a cold strike three on the inside
corner ranger suarez
has just pushed the phillies to one game
over 500.